dawkin lay knows what it is to wait  she's waited five months for news of her  nephew arrested for protesting against  myanmar's military coup  today she's waiting again  to see if he'll be among thousands of  inmates freed by the junta  no one knows who's coming out of these  prison gates  it's agony  [Music]  [Music]  buses carry prisoners to freedom  dawkins scours the windows to see if her  nephew's on board  [Applause]  but time and again  it's others celebrating  your mother is free your mother is free  from suffering this woman cries  a surprise clemency after months of  killing  not a sign of peace say critics but  political power play by a junta craving  legitimacy after being blocked by  neighbours from a regional summit  and while release brings relief  the newly freed remain defiant  as darkness falls dawkin lays still  waiting  waiting to hold her loved one  to bring him home  siobhan robbins sky news bangkok